während die kleinen betriebe und die
menschen große ängste und sorgen haben
vor einem kalten und vor einem langen
winter vor weiter krass steigenden
energiekosten wünschen sich politiker
der afg genau dass sie wollen einen
dramatischen winter
die afg streamt eine live veranstaltung
bei tik tok zu sehen und zu hören sind
dabei der eu politische sprecher der fdp
fraktion dr harald weil afd
fraktionspolitiker dr rainer kraft und
helmut wanitschek in denen offenbar
nicht bewusst ist dass die mikros an
sind
[Musik]
harald bei hunderte oft bild anfrage
zurück er habe keinen wunsch sondern
eine befürchtung ausgedrückt
[Musik]